yeah because i you talked about you know
when a new hype game comes out
then you just drop whatever you're
playing and just start playing that i
have like the opposite problem
i have i don't know what i don't know if
there's an actual term for it i think i
i think i'm gonna i'm just gonna coin a
term now yeah i get hype fatigue
right so so like there are times when i
see that
i see a new game like announced at e3 or
something yeah i see or
i i see all like the you know the
gameplay and like the developers
showing off gameplay footage and
trailers and i'm like i like follow
through that i'm like super super hyped
for this game
because i think i'm really really gonna
like this game and i get so
hyped that i kind of hype myself out of
it once
the game actually comes out like i used
all your hype yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's so weird like i was like that with
the final fantasy 7 remake
because i'm like dude i can finally
enjoy final fantasy 7
because it's removed the shitty part
that i hate about final fantasy the
turn-based combat and the random
encounters
so in theory i should love this game
because this is one of the greatest
jrpgs of all time everyone always talks
about it
i was hyped for it to come out i was
hyped for it for years
and then it came out and then i just was
just like maybe i'll play it later
that's a really good point i think that
league of legends killed my ability to
get hyped for games
yeah because i knew that at the end of
the day most of the time i would just
return to league of legends
yeah yeah so it didn't matter what game
came out anyway because i would play it
for a week and i'd be like
all right back to league yeah it's and
so now even though i don't really play
league anymore
even when a game that i probably am
excited for like is announced or
whatever i'm just like
while someone's on twitter going through
the you know like the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'm just like oh i mean yeah
it's kind of like that you know whole
thing of like oh like a new restaurant
just opened up that
everyone's [ __ ] hyped about i'll go
check it out but then you go have a meal
there
might be the best [ __ ] meal of your
life but then you know you'll be like
all right i'm going to mcdonald's
tomorrow
it's just it's just comfort food right
or comfort game yeah it's just like
there's always that like fallback of
yeah you know this is a cool game and
all yeah like i'm sure i'll love it if i
just kept going on with it
yeah but at the same time it's like i'll
i'll just replay this thing
at the time i wonder as well if you're
into story games more which i think the
people who are chasing like the hype are
more into story games because when
you're a multiplayer gamer
yeah mainly like me it's like well i'm
just gonna keep playing the same [ __ ]
game
so like why would i get hyped over
anything when if there's a new game i'll
probably end up switching to it if it's
a new multiplayer game yeah yeah
so it's kind of hard for me to get hyped
about just because it's like a
catch 22 for me right because i i really
value good stories
in video games but also like especially
now as an adult
i think i just have commitment issues
with games like unless i know
that i'm going to be committed to this
game for the next week of my life which
finding heart finding time to commit to
a game for the next week of my life is
like
a big [ __ ] commitment now it is it is
so hard
that sometimes i just go back to my
comfort food of just like maybe
replaying massive
like when when cyberpunk got released i
i was super super hyped about cyberpunk
and then it got released and then i'm
just like
i don't really feel like playing
cyberpunk i and i just started playing
mass effect again
because like you might choose your dick
size in mass effect
because i know the story of mass effect
i know i'm going to enjoy the story of
mass effect and
i know if i i i think over like
pre-overexposure in terms of like gaming
is
is a big thing for me because a lot of
people hype up games to know to no end
and
i don't think that people i don't think
in anime at least this is as big of a
problem
or as big of like a thing where people
do you know people get hyped about anime
as it's airing
people rarely get hyped about anime or
super super hyped about anime before it
starts airing but with video games
you have years and years to like pump
yourself up
for this game to come out cyberpunk
hyping up right it was ridiculous
i i am surprised though that i wasn't
expecting
i thought i was gonna be the only
nintendo simp on this at this table so
i'm glad that you have at least like a
couple of nintendo games here okay okay
okay so
let me ask you this was wind wake your
first zelda
it was the first zelda that i finished
that's normally how it goes yeah that's
usually
my favorite was like twilight princess
and i know that it's not the best one
because i think breath of the wild is
better than twilight princess yeah
twilight prince is still [ __ ] solid
yeah game but it's only because i like i
think that was the first one that i
finished
like when you finish a zelda game
there's something about it that feels
like so
yeah yeah yeah you're a kid yeah i mean
i i it was like really hard for me to
pick between
wind waker and uh breath of the wild i
was [ __ ] obsessed with breath of the
wild when i when it came out because i
remember
when i started getting into breath of
the wild um was the first time that i
came to japan with sydney
the first time the first time i met you
um and
i remember like i had a great time in
japan first time in japan of course
you're gonna have a great [ __ ] time
but i remember no matter how many times
no matter how many times i went to akiba
no matter how many times we hung out and
everything
at the back of my mind i was just like i
kind of just want to go i could be
playing
the wild right foreign
like i'm just like you know [ __ ] joey
man like oh come on come on joey
you're good but are you breath of the
wild dude i don't know about that
but you could have said that to my face
i would have been like you know what i
ain't mad
i kind of agree i don't have to agree
with you there to be fair though i
wasn't expecting sunshine for some
reason
okay out of order you don't seem like a
sunshine player why don't i seem like a
sunshine no i don't know you just don't
you two don't seem like nintendo game i
know i know you're not but
you definitely don't seem like that
because i think uh the the only re the
the only nintendo games out on here are
like my childhood nintendo games
yeah yeah because i was definitely a
nintendo kid i i was such nintendo simp
when i was a kid yeah
i i was like i i didn't i never owned
any other console apart from the
nes super nest n64 gamecube and it was
only after gamecube that i finally
ventured out which i
which is why i just didn't own a wii
right and i think since then the switch
is the first nintendo console i actually
owned
right and so i still i still like
out of all the nintendo games these two
pop outs me as the ones that i think
they're
like the most popular honestly
it's like most popular 3d mario and most
popular 3d zelda